>>Hertz here to speak to us, as part of our
2010 physically fit initiative.
Uh, Fred is a well known bay area lawyer who
specializes in legal and financial issues
pertaining to same sex and unmarried straight
couples.
He has appeared on the Oprah Winfrey show,
the Today show, NPR's talk of a nation.
He's regularly quoted as an expert in these
regards.
In publications like the New York Times, Harpers
Magazine, the New York Observer, the Advocate,
Out magazine and other publications.
He's a graduate of the University of California
Berkeley school of Law and has been practicing
in the Bay area in Oakland since 1990.
Fred: No, 1982
>>1982. All right. Good to know.
He is the author and co-author of several
books.
And please join me in wel -- in welcoming
him to Google.
Thanks.
[Applause]
Fred: Thank you so much.
It's, it's a real pleasure to work at a place
that is gay friendly and unmarried friendly
and non-traditional family trendy.
I have to say that I'm a regular Googler and
my last little, little episode, I was commenting
on the prop 8 trial about same sex marriage.
And about 2 weeks ago, just 'cause I thought
I was gonna get a question, I googled "Is
Vaughn Walker gay?"
He's the judge who's handling the prop 8 case,
and I think accurately so.
There were only 2 entries, 'cause up until
two weeks ago, there only were 2 blog sites
that commented on it.
And then, obviously your machines have been
hard at work because a week later when a San
Francisco Chronicle article outed the judge,
and I asked the same question, I think there
were like 12,000 entries, over a 1 week period.
So, just thought I'd let you know that your
work helps many of us out there.
I'm the author, or co-author of three NOLO
press books.
NOLO is a publishing company that's been around
for 38 years, dedicated to teaching people
how to handle legal issues themselves.
And, we have a legal guide for lesbian and
gay couples that this year is in its 30th
anniversary, 15th edition.
It's been continuously published for now 30
years.
We also have a book for straight unmarried
couples called Living Together: A Legal Guide
for Unmarried Couples.
And then my newest book, which is called Making
It Legal, is all about all the issues just
of marriage, domestic partnership and civil
union.
And we have that one for sale here at a discount
of $20.00, autographed copy and also some
coupons if you want to order it.
The other books are available at the NOLO.com
website.
So, what I wanna talk about in about 35-40
minutes are the issues of being unmarried
or domestically partnered, or married both
for opposite sex and same sex couples.
And talk about the financial issues, the legal
issues and a little bit on the political issues.
Now one of the reasons that this fits into
a financial fitness talk is that one of the
core issues is, about marriage is about money.
And what I try to, try to explain to people
all the time is that I'm not talking about
the right to marry.
That's a political cause that I strongly favor.
What I'm talking about is the choice to marry.
Whether you are straight and have the right
to marry, or whether you're in a gay or lesbian
relationship and you have the right to marriage
equivalent, or marriage in California.
And while people say it's not romantic, in
fact the major consequence of marriage or
state registration is financial.
And when someone said to me recently, "Well
that's not very romantic.",
I said, "Wait a second.
Isn't taking care of the person you love romantic?
Isn't making sure that the person you love
has a house if you should die romantic?
And isn't setting financial limits so that
you don't break up because of money conflicts
romantic?"
I actually think that's part of romance is
caretaking and issues of money and property
are about caretaking.
OK, so, oh and the other thing which Jeff
and I were talking about earlier today is
that one of the most interesting studies that
have come out around marriage is that married
people tend to save more.
Now, there's always a causation problem here.
Maybe it's just these boring conventional
savers who tend to get married.
You know, and these unmarried people are just
risk takers, but we don't think so.
We think it's actually that when you have
someone else who you are responsible for,
or who can mess up your life, you actually
pay attention to them in a different way.
So, I was noticing one of the signs from the
financial fitness talks about credit score.
Well if your spending habits are going to
wreck my credit score, I may pay more attention
to your spending habits than I would otherwise.
Or if your credit card debt is gonna cause
me to lose our house, I may start caring more
about your credit card debt.
I jokingly said that now that gay couples
can enter into marriage or its equivalent,
people are gonna start asking a different
set of questions when they meet somebody in
a bar, you know.
I don't think gay couples were, gay people
when they were cruising in a bar were asking
about credit scores or bankruptcy history
the way straight couples getting -- straight
people getting married, or their mothers might
ask.
So, first, what are the issues particular
to straight unmarried couples?
So here the real issue is on the whole, do
you want to marry or not?
And what's important to know is that as an
unmarried couple, and this
is true for gay or straight, you have no financial
merging unless you do it voluntarily by owning
a house together or buying a car together
or taking out a loan together.
There is something which is called palimony
or Marvin claims.
And that comes out of a case from 1978 where
Lee Marvin's girlfriend sued him.
What's great is this is, this is one of these
little legal insider things.
Why is it that the lead case about unmarried
couples is called Marvin vs. Marvin?
It's because she wanted people to think she
was married to him, so she took his last name
even though they never married.
But, in that case, the court said that in
California, a partner can sue his or her girlfriend
or boyfriend or ex if they can prove a contract,
even oral, or other forms of equitable claims.
But what's important, the take away for this
is, it is a ticket to a courthouse, but it
is not a winning ticket.
The rules for unmarried couples are so stringent
in terms of actually winning a claim that
almost no claimants ever win.
So what's important to know as an unmarried
straight couple is you own what's in your
name.
Your boyfriend or girlfriend owns what is
in his or her name.
If you do co-own a property, it's gonna be
presumed 50-50.
And you can make a claim based on an oral
agreement, but don't count on it; you need
a written agreement.
And in the living together book, we have sample
ingredients -- sample, sample agreements on
owning a house together, owning a car together.
And the other piece to know is that again,
unless there's an agreement, and presumably
a written agreement, in an unmarried couple
situation, neither will owe alimony or spousal
support to his or her ex upon breakup.
So, when you're thinking about your future,
when you're thinking about your retirement,
if you are an unmarried couple, you really
have to think about it as an individual.
And the fact that you have loved someone,
cared for them and maybe even helped them
in their career is not going to get you anything
if you break up later on.
So you have to think about your own retirement,
your own savings, and your own debts.
Now there are a few places that allow unmarried
straight couples to register as domestic partners.
But in general it doesn't get you any benefits.
Unless your particular employer or city gives
you benefits.
So, for example, Google as I understand it
does give benefits to unmarried straight couples.
So as long as you're at Google, you'll get
that benefit.
But if your boyfriend works down the block
at Hewlett Packard, you will not have a share
of his stock options just because you're a
Google domestic partner and getting health
insurance benefits.
What's interesting is that the state law that
allows what we call marriage equivalent does
allow older straight couples to register.
This is one of these anomalies where people
like, whoa, w-w-wait.
Why is it that in order to state register
you either have to be same sex or if you're
opposite sex, you can register if you're over
the age 62.
Anybody want -- there's nobody, is there,
probably nobody in this room over the age
of 62.
But does anybody know why there's that distinction?
>> Social Security.
Fred: And what is it about Social Security?
>> [Inaudible]
Fred: But it's specifically to preserve your
widowed benefits or divorce benefits.
There's one of the rules, one of the benefits
of marriage -- you all are much too young
to worry about this -- is that if you're the
…
>> [Inaudible]
Fred: [Chuckles] you look young.
If you are the low earner in your family -- the
housewife traditionally -- and your husband
predeceases you, one of the Social Security
rules is you can take your husband's Social
Security.
The idea is if you're the stay-at-home mom
or dad and your husband dies, you're counting
on his Social Security as a retired couple,
you can elect to take your spouse's Social
Security.
You can't take both, but you can take the
high earner's.
Well, if you remarry, you lose that privilege.
So the reason why older couples were grant
-- were allowed in to state register is so
they could get some of the state benefits
of domestic partnership, and not lose their
widow or divorcee benefits under Social Security.
It's a very small crowd, not many people do
it.
OK, so the key issues again for straight couples
are: Are we going to marry or not?
The other thing to know, and this is true
for both gay couples -- or will be true whenever
there's federal recognition even though there
isn't now -- is that the tax treatment is
very, very different.
Now, what's important to know, and I'll, I'll
just bring this up 'cause it comes up in the
decision making of straight unmarried couples
is that on the whole, there's a tax penalty
while you're together and a tax benefit when
you die or break up.
I find this very interesting.
We think we have this pro marriage policy.
Actually the way in which straight couples
that are married really benefit is when they
get divorced.
They actually pay a penalty while they're
married.
That's kind of interesting.
And the reason there is this penalty is that
if you are married, your incomes generally
are combined and for federal purposes, it
can push you into a higher tax bracket 'cause
you're part of a $300,000 a year couple as
opposed to if one person is making 250 and
the other person is making 50.
That $50,000 earner's gonna be in a low tax
bracket.
But once he becomes part of a $300,000 couple,
they're each in the $150,000 tax bracket and
higher federal taxes will result.
It's not so much an issue on the state of
California taxes because there's not the bracket
shift like there is for federal.
On the other hand, should you go through a
divorce or have a death, the survivor or the
divorcee will be able to get benefits whether
it's spousal support or inheritance tax free.
Whereas if you're not in a federally recognized
marriage, you will start suffering some serious
tax problems upon divorce.
So ironically, on the whole, what I ask when
people ask me from a tax point of view, should
I marry, I will say, "Yes you should, because
it will come in really handy if you get divorced."
I don't like to say when you get divorced,
people don't like to hear people talk like
that.
So I say, "If you get divorced."
I can say when you die, because people accept
that.
So, that's the core issue for unmarried couples.
Oh and one last thing about unmarried couples.
One of the things I work with a lot is the
transition for unmarried to married.
And one of the complexities -- and this is
especially true in California, but it's also
true in Washington State -- that if you get
married, your premarital life is run, is controlled
by non-marital law and you post-marital life
is controlled by marital law.
Which can lead to a lot of confusion if there's
subsequently a divorce.
So if you save money for 10 years unmarried
and then get married, the unmarried savings
will not be shared, the marital, post marital
savings will be shared.
If you're ten years unmarried, and ten years
married, you will be entitled to alimony based
on the ten years of marriage.
But if you wanted to make a claim for the
earlier ten years, you would have to make
it under a palimony claim.
And so for couples that have bought houses,
or earned money, or received stock options,
the date of marriage can have a huge effect.
Now this is having a big issue for gay couples
who now have the right to enter the marital
system, but it's an issue for straight couples
who may choose to marry at a certain time
or not.
And it can have very significant consequences
in the event of a dissolution or death.
OK, so that's the opposite sex couples specialty
section.
Now let me talk about some of the issues that
are particular for same sex couples.
Now, California, the best way I can describe
it is that there is this room of state marriage.
And it's a room that gay couples weren't allowed
to enter at all until 2005.
And starting in 2005, same sex couples who
either had previously state registered, or
newly state registered could enter the room
of marriage via domestic partnership.
And once they got into that room, it was the
same as being married.
Not the same social dignity, not the same
cultural legitimacy, but in terms of the technical
legal rights, they are the same.
Then to go through the last 5 years in about
2 minutes.
We had the marriage door open in June of 2008.
And then couples could enter the marriage
room through the front door of marriage.
And, in fact, there was this little legal
fiction which is that if they had entered
in the domestic partnership door, they could
actually momentarily step out and reenter
through the marriage door.
And end up in the same room they were in before.
And they could also get married in Massachusetts
and other places and it would be honored.
And then within about 5 months, the marriage
door closed, that was Proposition 8.
And again what's important is you could still
enter through the back door, but not the front
door.
There's a lot of interesting controversy.
I'm the, I'm the like, I'm not, I'm not so
interested in the social dignity issues as
I am in the legal technicalities because that's
my specialty.
I once said in a group of people, "I don't
care if I sit in the back of the bus as long
as the bus takes me where I'm going."
It was not well received.
But what's -- and the reason I say that even
humorously is to say, "You do need to understand
that domestic partnership does take you into
the marriage room."
And I say that also because there are a lot
of same sex couples who think because it is
not given the social and cultural dignity,
it doesn't have the legal consequences.
And let me just say, if you're the high earner
who's breaking up with your boyfriend who
now is claiming half of your net worth, you
will learn what it means to be married quite
quickly.
So then, now there have been several challenges
to proposition 8.
Unfortunately the California Supreme Court,
which just a year earlier had said there was
constitutional right to marry, a year later
kind of forgot about what they had said and
said, "Well, domestic partnership is really
enough, and it's ok if the voters take it
away."
I don't think that was a well reasoned decision,
I think it was a political cop-out.
And now there are 2 avenues of attempts to
undo proposition 8.
There is going to be a proposition on the
ballot, but it will not be on in 2010.
I think it's now close enough to the deadline
that I can say that the people who are advocating
to get it back on the ballot by 2010 have
not gotten enough signatures to get on the
ballot.
But it will be on in 2012.
And then there is the proposition 8 federal
case which has been fascinating because it's
an attempt to use the federal constitution
to undo proposition 8.
And under constitutional law, if there can
be greater protections under federal law,
they would trump the state rule.
Let me say, there's been a lot of talk of,
"Oh my god this is gonna end up in the US
Supreme Court and it's gonna be doomed."
I don't think it's ever gonna get to the US
Supreme Court.
And I'll say this and I, you know, I may be
wrong, I've been wrong on a lot of these issues
before.
But I think in this instance, if prop 8 is
thrown out, I don't think it's going to be
because the court finds that there is a national
federal right to same sex marriage in every
state of the country.
I think what's more likely they would say
is that because California courts legalized
same sex marriage, it was wrong even under
the federal constitution for the voters to
take it away.
And if the court rules that narrowly, then
it would only be a state issue, it would be
ruled on by the 9th circuit, and the US Supreme
Court wouldn't have to take the case.
The other is if by the time it gets to the
Supreme Court, proposition 8 has been overturned
in 2012 by the voters hopefully, there'll
be nothing for the court to rule on.
So I actually predict it won't get to the
US Supreme Court.
We'll see in a couple of years.
So the last piece about the prop 8 problem
had to do with, well what does that mean for
people who marry out of state?
Gay couples.
So, the prop 8 case that the Supreme Court
[Inaudible] people are ruled on did not issue
a ruling on this issue.
It was very maddening to people like me who
are trying to advise clients.
They actually said in a footnote, we're not
ruling on it 'cause nobody asked us to.
Not quite true, but that was the cop-out that
they took.
Well fortunately the California state legislature
and Mark Leno from the state senate got a
bill passed which says two things.
One is that couples that married out of state
or out of country before prop 8 passed, will
be considered married.
And couples that marry out of state or out
of country after prop 8 passed will have all
the rights and duties of marriage, but not
its designation.
This is one of these pieces of legislation
Like why didn't they call me ahead of time?
Because I know what it does mean.
It means that if you choose to go to Iowa
or New Hampshire or Canada and get married
-- whenever there is a rule that applies
to married people, it will apply to you.
You have to go through divorce court.
You're entitled to inherit if there's not
a will.
You have to pay alimony.
All those rights and duties count, but not
its designation.
I'm obsessed like – well, what do you put
on the deed to your house?
Bill and Steve, who got married in Massachusetts
[Audience Laughs] and have all the rights
and duties of marriage, but not its designation,
as community property.
I mean, what do you put on -- when the bank,
when you apply for a loan and it says are
you married, single, -- I don't think they
have an "other" form.
What I said is, "Write it all out and let
Bank of America worry about it."
But its gonna be very confusing.
My fav -- There's all these discussions going
on -- what are you gonna call this?
For those of you who are literary minded,
if you remember Henry James was a 19th century
novelist.
He wrote a lot about these closeted lesbians
in Boston.
And they got to use the term "Boston marriages".
So I like the idea of calling who entered
into a Boston marriage.
Somebody else suggested SLAM, Something like
a Marriage.
[Laughter]
Fred: You know, you could come up with a name.
But you can now do that.
So in California, if you're a gay couple and
you want the rights and duties of marriage,
you can either state register, or you can
go out of state and marry.
We're actually encouraging people to state
register even if they go out of state and
marry so that they will have clarity in the
state of California.
It's a little clearer for property and other
issues.
Now, just to give an update on other states.
Right now, we have full same sex marriage
in Vermont, New Hampshire, Connecticut, Massachusetts,
Iowa, and within a month we will probably
have Washington D.C.
The thing that's confusing about Washington
D.C. is that they did pass marriage, but it
has to go through a 30 day congressional hold
where anybody in Congress can try to overturn
it.
We don't anticipate there will be any, and
what's important to know is it's 30 congressional
days.
And actually Congress doesn't actually get
together all that often.
So even though it passed December 12th, they
have -- Congress has not met for 30 days yet.
It's anticipated to be about March 5th.
So when that happens, then that passes and
there's no congressional override, then there'll
be marriage in Washington D.C., which is I
think kind of cool.
You've got Washington D.C. where the federal
government is; you've got Iowa, actually a
very progressive state; you've got New Hampshire
which is not thought of as a very progressive
state -- having marriage.
We then have marriage equivalent.
And we had a lot of struggles within the book
about how to call these different states.
So, I've now called it marriage, marriage
equivalent and marriage lite.
And we have this in the chart in the book.
The marriage equivalence are the states where
you can enter the room of marriage, but not
its designation.
It's domestic partnership on the West Coast
or civil union on the East Coast.
And those states are Washington State, Oregon,
California and Nevada.
Good to know you can rush off to Las Vegas
and have a domestic partnership commitment
ceremony in the Elvis Chapel.
And then it also is New Jersey on the East
Coast and now Maine which had marriage but
then was taken away by a vote.
Washington D.C. was going to have -- I mean
Washington State, excuse me -- was going to
have marriage, but it got pushed out by the
ballot.
But the marriage equivalent did survive.
So those are the states that have the marriage
equivalence.
New York is a really interesting state.
New York does not offer marriage or domestic
partnership, but they, for, on the whole recognize
marriages or partnerships from out of state.
The one area where they don't is around taxation.
They still tax people single because that's
something that has to be changed by statute.
But as to property and kids, New York is pretty
much a recognition state.
Let me also just say that the other 37 or
so states do not recognize marriage or domestic
partnership.
There are a few states, New Mexico, Maryland
that are kind of iffy.
The reason why this is so important is that
if you live in one of those 37 states, or
you move to one of those states, chances are
at the moment if you're an opposite sex couple,
you're unmarried; you're still unmarried.
If you're a same sex couple, your marriage
or domestic partnership will not be recognized.
And that's very important in terms of property
or estates or powers of attorney if you should
live, move to a non-recognition state.
OK, so what are the key financial and legal
issues that couples should be thinking about
when deciding whether to enter the room of
marriage.
So obviously there's a lot of emotional and
social issues of -- are you a couple?
Are you recognized by your family?
Are you recognized by your church?
I completely honor the importance of those
issues; it's just not my territory.
So, I want to just park those out there, acknowledge
them, and go talk about the more concrete
issues and less spiritual issues of money,
property, deaths and the like.
So, what's important to know is that marriage
creates an economic unit.
Being married means you are in an economic
partnership with your spouse.
And, when they go up, go out every day and
as I said -- mentioned in one of the books,
one goes to the office, and the other goes
to the mall.
They are each doing it on behalf of this economic
partnership.
And so that income that was earned at the
office and that debt that was racked up at
the mall are shared.
And they are shared at the moment they are
incurred.
So for example if you're the non-working spouse,
you don't have to thank your husband or wife
for giving you half of his earnings; it actually
is half yours the minute it's earned.
And you don't have to ask your spouse to pay
half of your credit card debt, 'cause it was
his the minute it was incurred.
The concept -- and I actually find it kind
of, both appealing and problematic -- is that
you're a team.
And the team goes out every day and hunts,
or gathers or spends as the case may be.
And you do it as a team.
And the whole concept of it, obviously if
you think about it historically, it was actually
designed to protect the non-working partner,
generally the woman.
So she didn't have to ask her husband for
money; it was half hers the day it was earned.
Now, what I just described is the rule in
what's called the community property states
which are basically the states that come from
Mexican or Spanish heritage.
Wisconsin actually adopted it, but all the
other community property states are in the
Western United States.
And this is actually the Spanish rule of marriage
that got passed to Mexico that got passed
to California.
And it's called community property.
And it says you form a community or a partnership
when you marry, and it's all a team.
If you live in the other 35 or so, or 38 states
in this country, this is not the rule.
The rule is you each keep what's yours, but
if there's a divorce, the judge can pull from
either person's pot as is needed at the time.
So it's important to know this distinction.
Community property states it's 50-50 even
if one person has inherited wealth and the
other one doesn't.
If you're in a non-community property state,
the division is based more on what your financial
needs are at the time of a dissolution.
The other principal concept of a marriage
or a legal partnership is that you are taking
on an obligation that can extend beyond the
marriage in both directions – past and future.
The idea is that you are taking on this economic
partnership.
And so, for example, if my earnings, or what
I thought were my earnings are actually community
property, my boyfriend, now husband's, creditors
can come after my earnings, 'cause remember
my earnings are now half his.
So even for the debts incurred before I met
him, his creditors can come after what I think
of as my earnings.
This goes back to this question of the different
sorts of questions you should be asking the
people you meet.
I now have said, my new test is you should
be watching the mail of your intended for
at least a year, although I now just realized
I'm assuming that bills come in the mail.
[Laughter]
Fred: Obviously I'm outdated.
Because I used to say that if you're getting
dunning notic -- if your boyfriend is getting
dunning notices, and you're kind of looking
over his shoulder at the mail, you should
be able to see to what extent you're looking
to marry a deadbeat.
On the other hand, now I realize if it all
comes through the internet, maybe you need
to be looking at your boyfriend's internet
for the next year.
The other piece of it is that should there
be a dissolution, you can be on the hook for
support and payment of debts after the relationship
ends.
Now, a lot of people think that is really
a crazy idea.
Imagine this: you support your partner for
10 years; he leaves you and then you have
to support him for another 5.
It's like whoa, whoa, wait a second.
But the concept behind it is actually quite
important, it's important that people understand
it.
It is that while people are together, they
make decisions as a couple.
Somebody might say, "Oh, you, since you're
working at Google, I'll become a school teacher."
"Since you're working at Google, I'll become
an artist."
Well, 10 years later, if there's a breakup,
that artist, that school teacher is very vulnerable.
The other, which again if you ask a lot of
couples breaking up, they will often disagree
about this.
But the, again the fiction or the myth is
that to be a high earner, you gain from the
love and support of your partner.
Again, and we're going back to a family, a
hetero-normative tradition.
But the idea is that corporative executive
wouldn't have been able to get up in the morning.
Obviously you, I, as I saw today you have
laundry and food service here, but traditionally
those were provided by wives.
And so, the, the corporate executive could
work the 12 hour day because his or her spouse
was taking care or raising the children, or
taking care of the house or doing these things.
And as anybody with kids and a complicated
life can tell you, having two overworked parents
is crazy making.
And so the idea is that the high earner is,
in part, a high earner because of the love
and support of the spouse.
And therefore it's only fair, even after a
break-up that there be some financial help
to soften the blow of the dissolution.
So there actually is a valid policy reason
for these rules.
Oh one thing I forgot to mention for unmarried
straight couples.
California does not have common law marriage.
Common law marriage is the notion that if
you live together and act married for at least
a certain number of years, you can be sort
of drifting into the marriage rule even though
you never got legally married.
California does not have that; there only
are about 7 states that do.
So, you should never assume that just 'cause
you cohabit for a certain number of years,
you are treated as married.
OK, so, the last topic I wanna talk about
in this beginning time, then I'm happy to
take questions or talk further is what does
it mean to be in a same sex marriage or domestic
partnership now that we still have federal
non-recognition?
14 years ago, there was a law passed called
the Defense of Marriage Act.
You can think to yourself as to what it was
being defended against.
But it said that the federal government does
not recognize same sex marriages or partnerships
of any kind.
So, now that there is state marriage or its
equivalent, a same sex couple that enters
into a marriage or its equivalent is still
going to be federally single.
Now, for anyone who is in the financial world
or the insurance world or the legal world,
this is a real brain teaser and twister.
I jokingly have said to people in this field,
"Every night before you go to bed say 'California
married, federally single'."
And if you say it every night before you go
to bed, after about 3 months, you start having
these folds in your brain where you can process
it.
The reason why it's so hard is that everything
from financial planners to tax accountants
has always said, "Well married people have
community property, unmarried people don't
have community property."
Well now we have federally unmarried people
who have community property.
And for anyone who is in a state registered
domestic partnership or a same-sex marriage,
doing anything that intersects with the federal
government is horrendously complicated.
So, for example, and, and I have to say that
it's a lot easier now than it was two or three
years ago, and, because even people liken
to it have figured out a tax program for gay
couples.
The problem is is that the entire state tax
code is built on the federal tax code.
And throughout the state tax code, and if,
if you fill out your tax returns, it says
take line 42 from your federal tax return.
Well, the problem is if you're state married
and federally single, what do you do?
Well, in a word what you have to do is create
two federal sets of returns -- one is single,
one is married.
Use the dummy return you created as married
to create your state return, and do your single
for the federal files.
But that's just the beginning.
Let me give an example I'm dealing with right
now.
Just, this is your little brain teaser of
the day.
Couple gets divorced.
Bill is buying out Steve's half of the house
that they own.
They've owned it for 20 years, there's a whole
lot of appreciation.
Well, under state law, they're considered
married.
So, it is an exempt transaction -- meaning
Steve doesn't have to pay any taxes on the
money he gets from Bill.
But Bill does not get a step up in basis.
So when Bill sells the house in 10 years,
he has to pay taxes not only on his half,
but on Steve's half as well because his basis
which is used to calculate housing does not
go up.
And this would be true for a straight unmarried
couple under state law as well.
I'm sorry, under state, under, under federal
law as well because they're an unmarried couple.
But in California, Bill and Steve are treated
as married under state law.
Well when it comes to the federal law, they're
not considered married.
So if Steve gets more than $250,000 which
is the residential exclusion, he now has to
pay capital gains on that money.
But the money that Bill paid to Steve, he
can use as an increase in his basis in the
house so that when he goes to sell the house
5 years from now, he pays less capital gains.
Follow that?
So that means that when Steve, when Bill goes
to sell the house for 5 years, 5 years from
now, his state tax analysis is to what capital
gains he own -- owes is completely different
than his federal capital gains.
Well, every accountant in town has, if you
have an accountant and they keep track of
these things, they don't keep track separately
for federal and state.
They just have a basis for the house.
Well, you now have a federal basis that's
different than your state basis.
Another example is if Bill and Steve agree
that they're gonna wait 5 years before they
sell the house 'cause they want the market
to go up, but Steve moves out; he will lose
his federal exclusion from taxes because under
federal law, you have to sell within three
years of you moving out.
But if you were straight and divorced, there
is a rule that says if your deferral of the
house sale is in your divorce decree, the
three years doesn't start running.
So, the consequences are different state and
federal.
Well those are just a couple of the examples
of how complicated this is.
But federal recognition is not just about
taxes.
It also means you don't get to get this widower's
benefit from your Social Security, because
you're not in a federally recognized marriage.
It means you don't get to petition to bring
in your fiancée or fiance from a foreign
country because you don't have that benefit.
And when you talk about children and the issues
of parentage, you, from a federal stand point,
unless you have adopted your partner's child,
you won't be considered the legal parent of
your partner's child which can have all sorts
of consequences in terms of Social Security
and immigration and things like that.
Let me just say there is one good ruling on
Social Security on this.
But in general, you're not in a recognition
state.
Now, that dilemma of the lack of federal recognition
spills into all sorts of things: I.R.A. rules,
home loan rules, credit card liability rules.
Almost all of these are federally regulated.
So whenever you deal with the federal government,
you're not gonna be in a recognized relationship
which can create all sorts of problems.
And this problem is only gonna change when
the Defense of Marriage Act is repealed by
Congress which might happen in the next 3
or 4 years.
I don't think it's gonna happen in the next
1 or 2 years, and also could happen by a court
throwing it out.
And there is a court case in Massachusetts
seeking to do just that.
So let me stop at this point and before we
wrap up and talk about financial planning
and legal issues.
Any questions people have about any of the
things we've talked about or questions about
things I haven't talked about?
[Pause]
Yes.
[inaudible question]
Fred: Yes. Please use the mike because there
are people listening to this through an audio
connection.
>>So, I'm currently living with my girlfriend,
and we're talking about getting married.
And she's a PH.D and she has a tremendous
amount of academic debt.
If we get married, would I be on the hook
for that academic debt as well because it
was incurred before marriage?
Fred: Yes, well the answer is your income
would be on the hook.
If you have savings, or stock options that
you acquired before marriage, that would be
your separate property, and her creditors
could not come after that.
So if you have assets or savings, or stock
now, you'd wanna keep it insulated and not
co-mingle it.
But if you married, your post marital income
is community property, just as hers is.
And her creditors, including the student loans,
could come after your income as well as hers.
Yes.
There's one way out of this, and I didn't
mention this earlier.
Is that many of the marriage rules can actually
be opted out of through a pre-nup.
And so a prenuptial agreement or a preregistration
agreement, you can actually do an agreement
in your situation where you would agree or
she would agree that your income is separate
property and not community property.
And if you actually did such an agreement
and completely abided by it -- means no shared
savings, no shared credit cards -- you each
pay half of the mortgage out of your separate
checking accounts.
If you have such an agreement and you maintain
it, then her creditors could not come after
you.
On the other hand, if you got divorced, she
couldn't come after you either 'cause what
goes around comes around in that way.
So it can be protected in that way.
>> Well we already have a shared credit card,
so that's gonna be hard.
[Laughs]
Fred: Well you'd have to stop that.
You could stop that.
But yes, in the absence of a pre-nup, your
income can be tapped by her, her creditors.
And let me just also say, I regularly counsel
couples to, say, have a big party, have a
commitment ceremony.
But look, if right now you have the privilege
of your income not being tapped by her creditors,
why give them your income voluntarily?
It may make sense to defer marriage or do
a pre-nup to avoid that problem.
>> But I couldn't do a pre-nup just, just
against that debt.
Fred: No, no, you can't say.
[Laughter]
Fred: You can't say, it's all shared unless
B of A comes after you, yeah.
>> Hi, you mentioned that there was talk in
the recent past of people dissolving their
registered domestic partnerships when they
could get married.
Can you, can you expand on why people were
doing that, or if that's inaccurate?
Fred: Oh I didn't say they were dissolving
their domestic partnerships.
I said they were in registered domestic partnerships
and they were also getting married.
>> OK
Fred: You don't -- In California, and it's
true in Washington as well, you can marry
the same person you're domestically partnered
to.
It merely reaffirms the rights you already
had.
You don't have to dissolve your domestic partnership
as long as you're marrying the same person.
If you have a state registered domestic partnership
and you want to marry someone else, then you
have to dissolve it or it's bigamous.
>> I have, I have heard of talk through the
grapevine of instances in which people have
dissolved their registered domestic partnership
before they got married.
Fred: To the same person.
>> Yes
Fred: Well there are some people who did because
they were offended by the stigmatization of
that second class status, A.
And there were people who wanted to limit
the time period because they've been registered
for 5 years and now they were gonna be married.
And they didn't want their marriage, the marriage
rules to apply retroactively.
So they dissolved their domestic partnership
and then got married.
>>OK, OK.
Fred: The one thing that actually is tricky
let me mention.
This is actually one difference between domestic
partnership and marriage.
Domestic partnership has this archaic, sort
of artifact of an old system where if you
have no debts, almost no assets, no kids and
have been together less than 5 years, which
as I say applies to probably about 2 couples.
You can dissolve your domestic partnership
by simply filing a piece of paper with the
Secretary of State, and you don't have to
go through the court dissolution process.
There is no marriage equivalent of that.
So, that is one area where some people are
dissolving their domestic partnerships when
they still qualify for that, and then later
marrying because it cuts off the time period
controlled by marital law.
Yes?
>> If you have a legal domestic partnership
or civil union for a same sex couple, or a
marriage, whatever your state permits, and
then you go to another state that has something,
but it's not exactly the same thing, it’s
a civil union or a marriage or a domestic
partnership, what kind of transferability
is there?
Fred: The answer is it depends on the state
you're coming from, the state you're going
to and the week that you ask me the question.
So for example, New Hampshire now recognizes
marriage and domestic partnerships.
Massachusetts recognizes marriages but not
domestic partnerships, or civil unions although
there's a case to try to get them recognized.
New York now recognizes some and not others.
California now recognizes out of state marriages;
Nevada doesn't.
It's, I really mean it when I say -- it's
week by week, month by month.
There is no singular rule, and that's one
of the problems of having this patchwork of
systems is the confusion around portability.
And so, and the answer I also have to say
is what's true today may not be true tomorrow.
So if you're moving to another state, I don't
know what's gonna be valid in that state and
you may move to a state that doesn't recognize
it now but three years from now does.
So, we really, we're gonna be in a stage of,
state of flux until there is something singular
called marriage.
Yes.
>>Hi, If you...
Fred: Can you pull the mike down a little
closer?
>> Oh, ok I'm sorry,
It… as a same sex couple, if you have both
your domestic partnership and marriage…
Fred: Yes.
>>As far as like for employer benefits.
Fred: Yes?
>> Would it matter to change your status from
domestic partnership to marriage, or it doesn't
matter at all or…?
Fred: Well, here's the answer.
In, in California with very, very few exceptions
it won't matter.
But let me give you one example where it does.
One of the odd distinctions between marriage
and domestic partnership.
In marriage, you don't have to live together
to be married.
You can have a long distance marriage.
You can marry someone in prison.
You don't have to live together.
In fact, traditionally you weren't supposed
to live together until you got married.
Well, when domestic partnership first got
passed in 1982, 1984 in Berkeley, there was
great fear primarily around people with AIDS
pretending to be partnered with somebody to
get health insurance.
City councils were obsessed with this idea
that everybody with AIDS was gonna find somebody
and pretend to be partnered with them.
And so there was a residency requirement put
into that domestic partnership, and it has
lingered now for 28 years.
It's still in the domestic partnership.
So, for example, if you weren't living with
someone, but you were still in a relationship
with them, it's possible your employer could
terminate your domestic partner coverage on
the grounds that you're not living together.
Whereas if you were married, there wouldn't
be that requirement.
That's a small example.
The other issue is, and when we talked about
this, Jeff and I talked about this earlier
and with Bennett.
There's some employers that are providing
better benefits for domestic partners than
they are for married.
Because, for example, when it comes to issues
like COBRA, the federal government does not
require COBRA benefits for divorcing married
people -- I, I mean divorcing same sex married
people.
But some employers are providing them for
domestic partnership.
So there could be these little tiny areas.
There also might be some, well, let me correct
myself.
At the moment, under state law there's no
difference.
In the next few years, if there is federal
recognition, it is possible that there will
only be federal recognition for married couples,
not for domestic partners.
Because under the current proposal for the
repeal of Defense of Marriage Act, they didn't
want to create a new federal category.
So in that case, if there's a repeal of DOMA
and there's federal recognition, and you wanted
to have, to be free of the double taxation
for domestic partners benefits insurance or
you wanted to have an I.R.A. roll over, for
that you would have to get married and domestic
partnership wouldn't count.
So the answer is at the moment I don't think
it's a difference.
It may become a difference in the future.
[pause]
Well let me just wrap up by saying that these
decisions are not easy.
And, the one thing that makes it easier for
opposite sex couples is at least there is
national recognition, if you do get married.
And there is federal recognition if you do
get married.
And other then a few minor changes in marital
law, the law today is probably gonna be the
law a year from now.
For same sex couples, the rules are differed
from state to state; they're different from
state to federal; and they are gonna be different
from year to year, if not month to month.
And so for the same sex couples, and we talk
about this a lot in the book, you need to
think about what's most important to you now,
what's most important to you in the state
you live in now, and make a decision based
on what's most important to you now, knowing
that as the law changes, or your life changes,
you may need to change your plans.
Let me also point out that for transgender
couples, the laws are even more complicated
because your legal gender from state to state
may be different based on what the state laws
are and what stage of transition you're in.
And so whether you're treated as an opposite
sex couple or a same sex couple if one or
both the partners have gone through a sexual
transition can be even more complicated.
But let me just end by saying the right to
marry is not the duty to marry.
And that while everyone gay and straight should
fight for the right to marry, the question
of whether marriage for you and for this particular
person you're considering marrying, whether
that is right for you is an individual decision
that you need to make carefully, slowly and
with the knowledge that we try to provide
you in our books.
So thank you very much, and I hope you'll
buy a book or two and thank you for coming.